coué bienvenue à paroles autochtone mon
nom c'est melissa maulin dupuis et cette
semaine j'ai reçu une question de
richard qui me demande est ce vrai que
les autochtones ne sont pas inclus dans
la charte des droits et libertés du
canada ry charges comprend pourquoi la
question peut être posée parce que
pendant très longtemps on avait
l'impression que les premières nations
les inuits et métis avait des droits qui
était carrément différent du reste de la
population qui elle était touché par la
charte des droits et libertés
mais si je ne me trompe pas c'est
vraiment une des raisons pourquoi ne dis
même modifier la loi sur les indiens une
époque en 85
parce que mon article de la loi qui
disait que les femmes autochtones qui
mariait des non autochtones devenait des
non autochtone et vice versa les femmes
non autochtones qui m'a rien autochtone
devenaient des autochtones et c'était un
article de loi qui était vu comme
discriminatoire vis-à-vis des du sexe
des femmes
donc il avait dû être modifié cependant
je peux comprendre où on a l'impression
que on n'a pas les mêmes droits parce
qu'il ya la loi sur les indiens qui
vient quand même être une loi
d'exception sur le côté qui gère les
communautés autochtones et malgré tout
malgré la charte
il ya quand même une reconnaissance de
ces droits d'exception parce que là on
parle d'une loi d'exception mais on a
aussi des droits d'exception comme
protection de la langue les droits
territoriaux qui sont peut-être pas
couverts par la charte mais qui sont des
droits quand même issu des droits
humains de base
donc ça peut être très mélangeant de
voir la charte comme quelque chose
d'extérieur aux communautés autochtones
mais on est considéré jeudi entre
parenthèses comme des citoyens canadiens
par le gouvernement canadien est donc
cette charte le est censé s'appliquer à
tous les citoyens canadiens
mais on a quand même des droits qui sont
en dehors les autres citoyens canadiens
et ça ce sont des droits d'exception
merci beaucoup pour la question richard
j'espère que d'ailleurs si vous avez
d'autres questions vous n'hésiterez pas
à nous les envoyer et n'hésitez pas à
partager les vidéos bonne semaine